帮你试完在韩国当一天韩女
是什么体验
哈喽大家
9月份去韩国的时候体验了
变每3件套
剑了头发
化了韩装
还拍了美美的
还是剩一件一照
12花装
出发
每一大早
顶着这招
并不给你去化装了
我预约的这件是新开的化装是
化装是之前是张元英的化装时
那我一进去
就被这个化装品的数量和政企程度
证判倒了
强迫这门狂戏又没有
我给的餐烤装
这种是小水的这张
因为很多朋友都说我长得很像小水
那本人化装门力
十分有限
这次来想韩酒之间
放装一下
嘿嘿
化装时节线给我
修了个美碼
然后用了一品泡沫面膜来做装前打底
这次来小韩发现
他们现在都特别喜欢用这种泡沫面膜
很方便
那底装部分
先用了一个BB雙
全面打底
手法真的很溫柔的
来的我真是要快去找了
美帽就把它真的花的
超仔细
用了美粉美笔
眼睛
让美高四种工具
眼装化装时使用这三盘眼影混合的用的
都是几分色细的
那先大面几瀑色之后
来开始夹签毛
会先用打火机
弹了一下
静毛夹在讲
弄眼线高完成的整个眼线
部分之后
就开始吸化眼影加深运软了
那化装时给我展示了
它一抽替
来自咱们穿那的夹签毛
说他们现在都非常爱用
中国的夹签毛
监一又好用
那我也适备韩国人反向
它给我贴的这个夹签毛
我一开始真的是有点下达
我有点抗拒
因为我没有贴过这么长的
然后一转眼
我洗几了一个
韩式大窩产
我当时看我就觉得
静子里面的自己超级陌生
我已经做好了
翻成的准备了
不然小韩便美我的心情
总是像做过山车鱼
然后又又又再完善眼装了
眼装真的化了超久
我还体验到了这个
小韩传统
像我小木棍汤净
眼装部分结束之后
就开始折下了
整个底装完成后
我是感觉整体核心了很多
第一装是只用了并装红武
三红它是用这两盘混合大的
这两盘我都买了
但是我怎么打都打不出
它给我打的那个效果
果然还是技术比产品更重要
那化装是开始挑户红了
也是用了三四只混合出来的颜色
装容结束就开始做造型了
整体的效果就是这样
可能大家觉得我这十七万五花的直播直呢
下午我就带着这个装报
去拍海市针间照楼
现在小姐姐要带我上去拍照楼
我选了最贵挡位的
不是十六万很远的
到底会先给一个马嫂一下
选择想拍的风格
他们有很多背景颜色可以选
那我选的是这个色的
拍摄和修图的过程
不能够路向所以我只能口述一下的
拍照的过程超几块
我以为还在找角度
设计是他就跟我说
已经拍完了
就大概也就五分钟吧
那拍完之后
立马当着我的面就开始修图了
他连空气流汉和节碼都可以
跟一根的帮我画出来
我最后的成片就是会给一个
期待和相框还有真真账账
然后还有一个电子摆
会发到我的状况
因为我有选择困难圣
所以我用家选了一张真面子
谈与三件套体应完毕
现在是下午快六点钟
这个装划了五个小时
咱们就是洗铁
还是水光鸡
不能不说这个装容
真的是超级能大
我家外面奔波了一天
一点都没脱装
这一趟人的重逃了
很多很多东西
那我改天再跟姐妹分享吧
拜拜